i'm doing some more moving here
i'm making a movement pattern ready to
see
[Music]
hop hop jump jump spin
jump jump hop hop stop
that looks like fun can you teach me of
course
now it's a movement pattern
you ready
okay
[Music]
hop hop jump jump spin
jump jump hop hop stop ah right
now i'll try
[Music]
hop spin
jump oh
spin jump
hop
spin
spin
whoa
i'm so dizzy
that's because you did too many spins ah
now this is the movement piece you ready
okay okay
listening yes
hop hop jump jump spin
jump jump hop hop stop
i can't remember why
i have something that will help abby
phew you can use these colors to help
you remember the pattern oh awesome okay
uh the first two actions are hop let's
use purple for hop okay nice could you
hold that please abby thank you
hop
hop
[Music]
now the next two actions are jump uh
blue for jump oh yes
nice
colors jump
jump
now the last action is spin
green
perfect
thank you
okay
now i'll try
okay
hop hop jump jump spin
[Music]
jump jump hop hop stop
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you're right eddie the colors really
helped me remember you know you could
mix the pattern up or add another move
oh
oh
i might use this multicolored one at the
start and that means uh
jazzy hair
fun come on are you ready okay let's do
it you're ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
there was lots of jumping and hopping in
that game huh do you like to jump
everybody jumping
everybody jumping jumping jumping
everybody jumping just like this
everybody jumping jumping jumping
everybody jumping just like this
how about
sliding this tire ah come for a slide
too
everybody's sliding sliding sliding
everybody's sliding just like this
everybody's sliding sliding sliding
everybody's sliding just like this
well there's somebody sliding in the
story today but what do we do before the
story oh i know this pattern before the
story we look at the clock
what's the time on the rocket clock
today
well the long hand is pointing straight
up that means it's something o'clock
and the shorthand is pointing to the
eight
so it's eight o'clock
on the rocket clock
yes eight o'clock
set wings for takeoff
five
four
three
two
one
zero
standing by to see what's inside
it's a pot plant and a garden glove
[Music]